leute werden jetzt gerade geklärt dass
wir einen scherz vielleicht bekommen
aber er guckt man da etwas kita platz
bekommen bei 1 und 9 video ich habe noch
nie in meinem ganzen leben irgendwas auf
der straße aufgenommen so wirklich aber
heute ist irgendwie immer das erste mal
und zwar habe ich heute den markt dabei
aus einem ganz besonderen anlass und
würde ich wirklich nie den video mit ihr
drehen
aber der markt hat heute einen ganz
besonderen tag ja gerade schon gesagt es
ist wie sein geburtstag und zwar hat er
sein eigenes buch veröffentlich das
tagebuch nicht dass
und genau aus dem grund habe ich ihnen
heute mit dabei wir sind hier in köln
direkt vom dom
es regnet ein bisschen also das wetter
ist nicht so geil aber wir haben uns
gedacht wir ihnen heute die zweite
ausgabe ich weiß ja das video gesehen
hast ich tausche mich nämlich gerade
hoch weil sie den ersten part noch nicht
gesehen habt schaut euch den man
vielleicht hier in ganz kurzer
ausschnitt aus erzählt hin euro um diese
wm-coach vorsprungs ich finde wenn sie
bloss sechs und acht
ich bin mal gespannt was sich aus
neben dingen machen kann das mache ich
jetzt einfach mal iphone 7 plus und acht
+46 wie viel auch und wir versuchen
heute aus dieser handy hülle irgendwas
besseres zu machen ja das ist eine handy
hülle von dem rapper spongebobs so
kennst ihn das ding kostet 20 euro also
ich hab schon mal einen gewinn von gut
das ist jetzt gebraucht aber 20 euro
gemacht ich würd sagen wir fangen
einfach mal an und würde dagegen ist
bucht haus hall of fame ist natürlich
schwieriger als man denkt wer hat auch
irgendwas gegen die handy hüllen
na dann mal weiter die fragen warum
willst du fragen oder sollte ich frag
ich wollte noch einmal da musst du
fragen wir drehen gerade was für youtube
und zwar tauschen wir handy hüllen
also ich habe mit einer büroklammer
angefangen und ich versuche mir hat hoch
zu tauschen und habt ihr irgendwas zum
tauschen gegen handy halle 3 euro geld
geht leider nicht also nicht
dann alles klar gut dann so schönen tag
dann war das war wieder nichts gemein
alex geben einfach alex 1 alex wie
vielleicht muss ja etwas sagen ja was
geht
ich bin youtuber alex ich möchte durch
ja wir brauchen ganz dringend eure hilfe
und zwar hier so eine handy hülle
wir haben uns runter getauscht von der
büroklammer zu dieser handy würde und
wir wollen jetzt irgendwann zu einem
handy kopf habt ihr euch hätte ich sie
uns geben können nicht wir brauchen auf
jeden fall irgendwas das besser ist als
ihr handy hülle von euch kennt das muss
auf jeden fall andere fragen
youtube mama sagt darf ich nicht ich
glaube in belgien dürfen wir kein
youtube hat hier ganz viel eingekauft
wird hier gerade was für youtube ich
hoffe es gegeben aber ich glaube dass du
kannst du auch machst du okay aber da
warst du schon oder ist nicht mehr
gültig für mich jetzt phase und
abonnieren dann habe ich einen mehr
und woher kommst du okay noch mal george
irgendwie glaube ich hatte er keine lust
so wir gleich competition handy hoch ob
irgendwas zum tauschen
vielleicht also ein handy hoch als wären
wir eine büroklammer angefangen und wir
suchen jetzt irgendwas machen
was dabei ergeben sich also sicher nicht
so ein richter hat gegen die amylose
skins kann sogar noch genau eine schicke
ihnen ähnlich wenig unter wert
die haben schon ein bisschen was infos
in der hand
das ist bestimmt locker trade
weggeschickt entschuldigung
habt ihr kurzzeit wir tauschen uns hohe
von der büroklammer und gucken wo wir
ankommen jetzt haben wir in der handy
hülle ab die ebenfalls zum tauschen
im besten fall besser ist als ich würde
ja wir haben hier eine handy hülle
wir haben uns hoch getauscht von der
büroklammer zu sonstiges habt ihr
irgendwas zum tauschen dafür was hoch
tauschen
naja also machen auf jeden fall
irgendwas oder irgendwas kann auch
gleichwertig seien irgendwie sowas
ich werde darüber im prime markt das so
alles so günstiger kann auch das ist
auch unsere handy würde immerhin
also ich muss sagen ich bin fast in
meinem latein am ende gerade irgendwas
muss ist doch gefangen
da sind jungs die wahrscheinlich auch
aus belgien kommen geht nicht ergebnis
was ist mit diesen kopfhörern
guck mal die welle wegen des anspruchs
ist limitiert
dass man also bei den kopfhörern bist du
raus
naja sind die echt original und jacke
ist von dir sonst galt neven dumont die
es gibt
als weiß ich wenigstens dass meine haare
man jetzt fertig fast kopfhörer gehabt
wir gehen jetzt zu leben meint es klappt
nicht immer so kurze frage
wir machen ein youtube-video muss uns
hoch tauschen wir sind gerade bei einer
handy hülle und auf der straße klappt
das nicht so wirklich und wir fragen
jetzt mal ins tor
wie ihr vielleicht irgendwas hat was ihr
gegen moment diese handy halle tauschen
würde wenn nicht ist auch nicht schlimm
aber man kann ja wenigstens mal fragen
leute werden jetzt gerade geklärt dass
wir einen shirt vielleicht bekommen aber
er guckt man da also dafür rein kommt
doch kommt auch auf youtube und so also
genau ist fein die groß aus davon fragen
was du etwas kostet
exklusive kollektion mit justin
timberlake ist noch gar nicht also kann
man sagen eigentlich noch teurer
ich würde dann ich würde dann ja genau
vielleicht behalte ich das jetzt auch
einfach selber danke megaprojekt leute
lieber ist es toll geht hier hin und
deswegen die werbung machen für
irgendwas köln schildergasse 84 8 viel
spaß was hast du von handy einfach 7
damit wollen jetzt so weitermachen oder
das so las er weil es ist ja sage ich
mal was limitiertes das wollen die leute
eigentlich haben auf der straße weil das
gibt es ja noch da und ich glaube das
sind immer lag fans würden das sofort
nehmen oder leute wir sind jetzt
wirklich schon eineinhalb stunden
unterwegs auf den street und das ding
ist eigentlich müsste ich schon längst
wieder zu hause sein deswegen jetzt die
frage machen wir noch weiter oder sagen
wir vielleicht machen wir noch im
nächsten partner irgendwann muss ja weiß
ich nicht ob du also das kriegst auf
jeden fall besser getauscht als ein
handy hat so leute werden jetzt
entschieden wir hören erst mal auch an
dieser stelle würde ich noch mal gerne
sagen danke dass du dabei warst du hast
wirklich so ein bisschen mut
zugesprochen die ganze zeit kauft seinem
buch das ist jetzt erhältlich wo an ein
wo gibt's das thalia hugendubel aber
sondern es geht um 100 praxen zu hause
selbst machen könnt und leute auf mich
jetzt hier oben werbung einblenden wegen
namens sendungen so oder so also hat
eine menge spaß gemacht lassen noch nach
oben da wenn wir noch ein paar tränen
soll wir sind auf einem guten weg jetzt
würde ich sagen und haut rein schreitet
auch beim nächsten video wieder ein wenn
es heißt alex